bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
l'antenne de public sénat ce matin me
vous proposons de revoir sur notre
antenne aujourd'hui une audition qui a
eu lieu mercredi dernier au sénat une
audition de la commission d' enquête sur
le rôle des banques dans l'évasion
fiscale cette commission entendait
mercredi dernier un ex cadre de la
banque d'affaires suisse rail pierre
condamin gerbier lors de cette audition
sur l'évasion fiscale notamment vers la
suisse est bien pierre condamin gerbier
a affirmé détenir une liste de 15 noms
de ministres passés ou actuels qui
détiendrait un compte en suisse
alors pour l'instant pierre condamin
gerbier n'a pas transmis ces éléments à
la justice du coup il y a quelques
doutes autour de cette liste c'est ce
qu'elle existe réellement
ou alors est-ce que c'est le fait de
l'amertume d'un un ex cadre de cette
bande qui a été licencié toujours est il
que dans la tente d'avoir à bien des
nouveaux éléments autour de cette liste
nous vous proposons ce matin de
réentendre cette audition donc devant la
commission d' enquête sur le rôle des
banques dans l'évasion fiscale très
bonne audition à tous sur notre antenne
bien écouter alors mes chers collègues
ne sont plus à temps même s'il ya
quelques deux minutes près nous sommes
un peu en avance je vous propose de
poursuivre l ses auditions par celle le
monsieur pierre condamin gerbier qui est
gestionnaire de fortune ancien associé
gérant d'une organismes dont nous
parlera est certainement tout à l'heure
monsieur devant notre commission
la règle et devrait t serment avec les
conséquences évidemment qui découle de
cette prestation de serment
alors monsieur prêtez-vous serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure
merci beaucoup
comme nous l'avons fait précédemment
nous allons organiser leur je dis bien
leur car pour des questions qui nous
échappent des contingences dont nous ne
sommes pas les maîtres
nous devons impérativement quitter cette
salle à 18 heures maximum donc je vais
vous laisser la parole pendant une
dizaine de minutes pour présenter le
sujet tel que vous voulez laborde et
puis après notre rapporteur animal des
bars en posant les questions qu'ils
souhaitent travaux poser et puis
éventuellement mes collègues l'enrichir
on le développe rond tout ça dans le
cadre d'une heure et ça y est nous
n'allons plus gunner à vous merci de me
recevoir ce soir en guise d'introduction
je vais peut-être vous dire quelques
mots sur mon parcours de façon à laisser
peut-être plutôt le temps qui nous est
imparti qui est précieux pour vos
questions
mon nom est pierre condamin gerbier j'ai
42 ans je suis français et depuis 20 ans
je travaille dans un domaine qu'on
appelle le family office qui est un peu
différent du métier de banquier privé
puisque les gens qui travaillent dans
ces bureaux familiaux pour utiliser leur
la traduction française s'occupe
évidemment du placement des liquidités
des investissements d'un certain nombre
de grandes familles internationale mais
j'allais dire agissent essentiellement
comme super intendant super secrétaire
privé régisseur pour le compte de ces
familles et gère la quasi-totalité des
différents aspects de leur vie
personnelle et professionnelle de
véritablement la gestion du quotidien
dans ce qu'elle peut avoir de plus
répétitif et terre à terre jusqu'à des
aspects beaucoup plus complexe en en
matière de philanthropie en matière
successorale d'art d'immobilier de
bateaux d'avions d'éducation des jeunes
générations les domaines sont
extrêmement nombreux j'ai eu le plaisir
de faire ce métier dans deux
environnements l'environnement anglo
saxons au service d'une grande famille
d'armateurs grecque et d'une grande
famille française étant basée à l'époque
la londres mais voyageant dans la
plupart des places qu'on qualifierait
aujourd'hui offshore du monde anglo
saxon pour le compte de ces familles et
des familles avec lesquelles elle était
en affaire avec lesquels elle avait aidé
des relations personnelles et
professionnelles et je suis j'ai quitté
ce monde anglo saxon toujours dans le
même métier en 2004 pour prendre
résidence en suisse
la société que vous mentionniez tout à
l'heure sans la nommer à savoir à
l'époque il n'était pas ben qu'ils
étaient négociants en valeurs mobilières
reyl & company mais ayant proposé de les
rejoindre en suisse pour développer ce
métier de family office et d'y
développer les synergies avec leur
métier historique et traditionnel de
gestion privée puis de de gestion de
gestion bancaire
dans ce cadre là pour le compte de ces
de ces grandes familles françaises et
non française beaucoup de ces familles
étrangères avait des intérêts importants
en france
j'ai eu l'occasion véritablement au
quotidien d'être témoin des pratiques de
l'ensemble de leurs conseils et
notamment de leur conseil bancaire
banque française sise à l'étranger
banques étrangères de banques
européennes ou anglo saxon est de
constater je crois à peu près la
totalité des palettes technique et
schémas qui ait pu être imaginé depuis
20 ans mise au service par ses banques
et en particulier par nos banques
françaises au service de ses clients
internationaux pour dans certains cas
aider à une optimisation de la fiscalité
de ces familles en restant dans la
stricte le district paramètres des lois
des juridictions dans lesquelles ces
familles avaient des intérêts personnels
et professionnels puis quittant la
simple optimisation pour aller dans un
accompagnement d'activité d'évasion au
sens de d'exil fiscal notamment des
personnes physiques et des structures de
détention de leurs actifs jusqu'à la
fraude la plus en plus avérée la plus
sophistiquée telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
avec peut-être beaucoup de fausse
naïveté découverte dans l'environnement
française au travers de la sphère ubs
ubs n'ayant rien fait d'autre que ce que
l'intégralité des banques suisses et
étrangères présentes en suisse n'ont
fait sur le territoire français si ce
n'est qu'elle a mené cette pratique à
une forme d'industrialisation qui fait
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui que c'est la tête
de l'ubs et s qui passe au dessus du
parapet mais je crois que vous pouvez
prendre
on pourra y revenir si vous le souhaitez
l'ensemble des représentations de ces
banques privées en france et il n'y en a
pas une pas une qui n'est utilisé ses
bureaux parisiens aux régionaux non pas
six mais superficiellement pour y
attirer une clientèle résidente
française transparente clientèle privés
ou institutionnels
mais véritablement pourri
établir des filets de pêche destiné à
accompagner les besoins d'un certain
nombre de petites moyennes et grandes
fortunes françaises à la recherche de
techniques de non déclaration ou de
fraude les accompagner en suisse et puis
l'environnement suisse changeant à son
tour les accompagner plus loin sous
d'autres cieux plus distant mais aussi
au travers de techniques plus
sophistiquées plus opaque
je tiens à vous préciser au passage que
contrairement à ce que je peux lire dans
les médias français notamment
non seulement mêmes suite aux affaires
que nous avons connu très récemment dont
l'une m'a concernés comme témoin
un titre très très particulier non
seulement ces pratiques ne s'arrête pas
mais elles continuent elles ne font que
se sophistiquer mais elle continue et
elle continue également sur le
territoire français donc voila voila un
petit peu le témoignage d'ensemble que
je me suis proposé de venir vous
apporter aujourd'hui mes interventions
dans les différents médias comme vous
avez pu le voir dates de long en fin de
longue date ils datent de 2006 2007 à
l'occasion de
du mandat politique que j'exerçais à
l'époque en suisse où j'étais le
représentant officiel de l'ump et où
j'ai dénoncé les pratiques de ma famille
politique ce qui montre aujourd'hui ma
ma motivation et une motivation de
citoyens français dont la voix commence
à devenir plus fortes et haute que celle
du professionnel qui était également que
j'ai également été pendant pendant 20
ans et aujourd'hui ce que je constate et
je constate depuis 20 ans est une très
large utilisation par l'ensemble des
personnalités et partis politiques de
l'ensemble de l'échiquier français des
techniques mises à disposition par ces
intermédiaires financiers banques
françaises inclus mais pas seulement et
que aujourd'hui je constate et constaté
depuis 20 ans une immense hypocrisie
lorsque l'on regarde la façon dont les
suisses ont traité l'affairé ubs quand
elle a concerné les états unis et la
façon dont le laisser suisse et l'ubs et
s traite les difficultés qui les oppose
aujourd'hui aux autorités françaises
on a l'impression d'avoir de ne pas
avoir la même banque en face de soi
alors certes le marché américain n'est
peut-être pas n'a pas la même importance
que le marché français en cas de perte
de licence bancaire pour une maison
comme ubs
mais je crois que ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui même la direction
actuelle continue à nier des pratiques
pourtant sont avérées par de très
nombreux témoins et qu'il ya un
sentiment d'impunité de la part de cette
direction appuyé par sa part sa
direction générale suisse lié au fait
que l'ubs et s comme tout un tas
d'autres banques françaises ont du grain
à moudre et une monnaie d'échangé
vis-à-vis de la france parce qu'ils ont
dans leur livre un certain nombre de nos
hommes et femmes politiques ce qui
n'était pas le cas
ou en tout cas beaucoup moins le cas
pour les états unis
donc au delà des rapports de force
économiques
je crois qu'il y a clairement une
différence d'appréciation et c'est tout
un pan du système qu'on est en train de
soulever les pratiques qui ont été
découvertes à l'occasion de la faire dit
la sphère cahuzac ne sont pas très
clairement oui c'est évidemment aussi le
mensonge d'un homme mais c'est surtout
le mensonge d'un système c'est le
mensonge de la classe politique
française sur tous les bords de
l'échiquier encore une fois depuis
depuis finalement 1934 je vous rappelle
que les suisses l'ironie de l'histoire
c'est que les suisses ont inventé le
secret bancaire parce qu'ils se sont
fait piéger en france à paris à
l'occasion d'une affaire qui en 1934 été
qualifiée de la sphère de la banque
commerciale de bâle qui a failli faire
tomber le gouvernement et rio et lorsque
les des bons les bons d'obligations
était payé en liquide est remis à
différents membres de ce gouvernement
dans les locaux de cette banque
si vous relisez sur internet le détail
de cette histoire vous avez 80 ans avant
quasiment le script de la sphère cahuzac
donc en fait on découvre aujourd'hui
quelque chose que nous praticiens
impliqués ou ou témoins de du monde de
la gestion de fortune anglo saxons
également du monde de la gestion de
fortune des pays de droit civil comme la
suisse constatons depuis depuis vingt
ans mais c'est ce témoignage que je me
proposais de vous de vous apporter de
répondre j'espère le plus précisément à
vos questions pas seulement comme
technicien mais surtout comme praticien
ce soir alors qu'ils n'ont pas perdre de
temps pour ce qui est des questions et
je suis immédiatement passé la parole à
notre à porter merci monsieur bré non
monsieur konan ya bien merci de
l'introduction question d'abord plus
personnel vous avez je crois été
licencié de l'établissement réel en 2009
c'est bien cela absolue en 2010 le midi
cependant est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer les circonstances le
déroulement de gym agile que ça a marqué
une rupture tout point de vue
est-ce que c'est cela entre autres qui
vous amène aujourd'hui à tenir les
discours que vous tenez qui sont
évidemment très percutant ensuite une
question beaucoup plus concrète parce
qu'on essaie dans cette commune nouvelle
commission denquête de comprendre les
mécanismes à l'oeuvre dans les
constructions etc
les contacts le ticket d'entrée d'un
patrimoine c'est combien à partir de
quel niveau et ont pris en compte par un
établissement comme celui dans lequel
vous travaillez par exemple ensuite vous
dites que ces pratiques continuent
aujourd'hui c'est bien cela oui malgré l
affaire ubs en cours malgré tout ce
qu'on peut entendre et voir ça veut dire
que y'a aucune réserve aucune prudence
dans du côté des banques suisses on est
toujours sur les mêmes mécanismes mais
vous dites que c'est ça continue plus
belle si j'ai bien entendu c'est bien
cela de plus belle différemment mais je
fais vraiment là ça se sophistiquent ce
vous pourriez illustré très concrètement
jeu réagir très rapidement à votre
première question avant de venir à la
troisième qui est un peu plus complexe
dans sa réponse j'ai effectivement été
licencié de chez rl pour des raisons qui
n'ont à l'époque rien à voir avec
l'actualité présente le métier de family
office est un métier ou de nous nous
nous devons d'être les ambassadeurs sans
aucun conflit d'intérêts de ces de ces
grandes familles or en dernier ressort à
l'activité historique d'une maison comme
réel c'est véritablement de gérer les
liquidités de ses clients
néanmoins nous family office home à tout
moment obligé de mettre en concurrence
lorsque nous sommes nous avons pour
maison mère une banque cette banque avec
leurs concurrents de façon à obtenir les
meilleures conditions pour nos clients
et il est arrivé cette cet état d'esprit
était celui de la famille réel quand
nous avons décidé de nous associer
ils ont compris que ce family office
pour être pour avoir du succès et dieu
sait qu'il en a eu se devait d'être
indépendant mais quand ils ont voulu
obtenir leur licence bancaire
ils ont recruté toutain une nouvelle
direction qui ne comprenaient pas ce
qu'était un family office et
fonctionnait vraiment comme des
banquiers privés pur et dur avec des
objectifs de maastricht quantitatif et
n'ont pas compris que ce family office
devait rester indépendant et parfois
choisir certains concurrents à la place
de sa propre maison mère mais gagné par
ailleurs très suffisamment d'argent pour
pourquoi
tribus et la réussite du groupe j'ai
dénoncé ces conflits d'intérêts et ayant
une divergence de vues avec cette
nouvelle direction
j'ai annoncé mon départ et mon départ a
été précipitée par ce que mal vécue
comme une trahison d'autant plus que
certains la plupart nos clients côté
famille office sont partis en même temps
que moi l'établissement réel a trouvé
une bonne raison de me licencier
on peut il revenir dessus si vous voulez
ça relève plus de l'anecdote qu'autre
chose mais tout ça pour vous dire que ma
démarche d'aujourd'hui j'ai toujours été
très proche de françois et dominique
rennes françois reyl était un ami il n'y
a aucune vindicte personnelle aucune
vengeance j'aurais eu d'autres occasions
beaucoup plus douloureuses et concrète
de d'exercer cette vendange si j'avais
dû voulu le faire depuis 2010 j'aurais
préféré que l'actualité qui est exact ne
concerne d'ailleurs par l j'aurais eu
une parole probablement encore plus
libre que je ne l'est que je ne résume
donc voilà donc pas de pas de deux de
vengeance envers un établissement ouvert
untel ou untel deuxième deuxième
question vous m'avez posé j'ai beaucoup
lu à l'occasion de la sphère cahuzac il
était suspicieux que nenê que le solde
du compte ne soit que de 600000 euros
la plupart des cas rappelons que lorsque
monsieur cahuzac ouvre son compte chez
reyl réel est un gérant indépendant un
tiers gérants comme les qualifie les
suisses qui veut grossir qui a beaucoup
d'ambition et qui donc à des démarches
commerciales qui sont très ouvertes donc
à l'époque ils font feu de tout bois et
j'ai vu des comptes s'ouvrir même pour
cinquante ou soixante quinze mille euros
chez reyl à l'époque donc en soi c'est
minimum d'ouverture de comptes qui ont
été repris par les journalistes ne me
semble pas dans le cadre de réel et de
la fère cahuzac pertinents c'est un peu
un jeu de dupes
cette histoire de taille d'actifs
minimum de la part des banques suisses
parce que c'est un argument commercial
plus vous avez des minimums élevé plus
vous apparaissez élitiste plus vous
apparaissez comme un établissement qui
n'a finalement pas besoin de nouvelles
affaires or les banques suisses ont tout
peut-être un certain nombre de
départements dans lesquels les équipes
ne travaillent qu'à partir d'un certain
minimum mais en tout cas
elles ont d'autres départements qui font
feu de tout bois et qui collecte à des
des niveaux de taille de fortune
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus restreint
donc aujourd'hui je dirais que cela
relève de la communication
cela relève du marketing et que n'ait
pas apprécié uniquement la taille des
actifs mais aussi les portes qui peuvent
être ouvertes par tel ou tel client est
un client qui n'a peut-être que quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros mais qui a
de l'influencé qui a des réseaux qui a
la possibilité de donner accès à des
clients qui eux sont vraiment vraiment
détail de fortune importante sera
acceptée avec bonheur dans la mesure où
on ne cherchera pas une rentabilité
économique mais tout simplement on
cherchera l'accès à l'accès à différents
cercles d'influencé pour revenir sur
votre sur votre troisième troisième
question je crois que le monde a changé
mais pas tant que ça auparavant la
suisse était à la fois la partie
software et la partie hardware c'est à
dire que l'ingéniérie au sens assez
cynique du terme
on est d'accord patrimonial qui
permettait la fraude était en suisse et
les moyens de la mettre en musique était
également en suisse les structures les
équipes les logistiques les outils
informatiques notamment étaient en
suisse aujourd'hui la suisse a gardé la
partie software c'est à dire vous avez
toujours un certain nombre de
professionnels intra et extra
banques qui réfléchissent aux solutions
internationales mais ces solutions
aujourd'hui elles vons implémenter c'est
la partie hardware bien en dehors de la
suisse et la communauté européenne
notamment au moyen-orient notamment en
asie même si on a parlé beaucoup de
singapour je crois pas que ça à
singapour a été un épiphénomène pour
essayer de contourner à l'époque la
retenue à la source sur l'épargné
européenne mais ça a été une solution
d'urgence une solution à court terme
aujourd'hui hormis le moyen-orient il y
à une juridiction qui accueille la
plupart des très grandes fortunes
internationales incluant les très
grandes fortunes françaises qui est en
compte pourquoi parce que c'est un dans
ces questions de lutte contre les places
offshore c'est une question une question
de rapport de force tout simplement
économique notamment si en suisse si on
fait pression sur la suisse les dés les
déboires avec les états unis l'ont
montré la suisse ne peut pas se
permettre d'avoir ces nestlé roche
novartis firme est nichée et givaudan
qu'ils ne puissent plus exporté en
europe ou aux états unis donc les points
de pression sont immédiats et très
douloureux derrière hong kong il y à la
chine et la chine la chine le monde
tient la chine et la chine tient le
monde mais je crois que la chine tient
plus le monde que le monde ne la tient
parce que la chine 1 milliard de
consommateurs un peu plus si demain les
marchés extérieurs a été fermé et je ne
pense pas qu'on ira déranger les chinois
pour des questions de simple évasion
fiscale de nos propres citoyens
donc aujourd'hui l'argent est allé plus
loin
les structures se sont sophistiquées on
parle beaucoup des trusts c'est un peu
la tarte à la crème du journaliste
français elle est russe les trust ont
beaucoup été utilisé
mais c'est un instrument de droit anglo
saxon qui pas aussi des c'est nous qui
l'avons fourvoyé le trust lth trust au
départ est là pour pour pour les
protections familia la protection
d'incapables la préservation de
patrimoine la cohésion d'entreprise la
gestion de fonds de pension des motifs
tout à fait louable est licite et c'est
très largement une poignée d'avocats
d'avocats fiscalistes parisien en
coopération avec leurs collègues
londoniens qui ont compris qu au travers
du trust on pouvait faire tout autre
chose
mais tout ça aujourd'hui et est beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins utilisé ce qui est
utilisée finalement c'est les bâtons que
la france donne pour se faire battre
elle même notamment l'assurance vie
luxembourgeoise aujourd'hui c'est le
seul moyen d'ouvrir un compte auprès
d'une banque suisse sans que les
titulaires réelle figure dans les
documents d'ouverture de comptes désigné
comme ayant droit économique
pourquoi parce que la france a
simplement impliqué des tests des textes
européens et notamment en matière
d'investissements immobiliers d'ailleurs
quelque chose que nos amis qataris
maîtrise parfaitement
lorsque vous achetez un bien immobilier
en france au travers d'une structure de
droit étrangers l'administration fiscale
française elle-même vous donne vous
donne deux possibilités la première qui
est de révéler qui est derrière cette
structure ou si vous ne le souhaitez pas
elle l'admet tout à fait mais elle vous
dit ben écoutez il vous en coûtera 3 %
la valeur de marché du bien par an donc
là ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est cher
pour pour un investisseur donc ce qu'ont
fait les acteurs
les acteurs bancaires notamment vous
remarquerez d'ailleurs que toutes les
filiales de banques suisses en france
sont aussi broker en assurance c'est pas
simplement pour vendre de l'assurance
vie c'est pour utiliser la technique que
je vais vous décrire qui est que lorsque
les textes européens disent la chose
suivante lorsque vous utilisez un
contrat d'assurance vie dont la société
d'assurance dont le prestataire et ou
bien une société européenne ou dont la
maison mère est cotée sur un marché
européen
eh bien vous avez le droit pour des
questions de respect des lois
concurrentiel intra europe d'ouvrir de
faire l'acquisition pardon du bien
immobilier français au travers la
structure intermédiaire étrangères en
disant au fisc français que la
contrepartie réelle et la société
d'assurance vie donc axa luxembourg peu
importe
lombard internationale peu importe et
l'administration française sans s'en
contente c'est à dire qu'elle considère
que oui bien sûr il ya un contrat
d'assurance-vie ya probablement un
souscripteur et puis des bénéficiaires
mais on accepte que finalement ce soit
pourvu qu'elles soient cotées sur un
marché européen que ce soit la société
d'assurance vie qui soit désigné comme
l'ayant droit économique et on va donc
aller les chercher dans un endroit
favorable en europe qui est en
particulier le luxembourg et on n'ira
pas plus loin
et donc aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
très largement utilisé la plupart des
comptes sensibles en suisse au delà des
comptes qui sont partis à singapour qui
finalement de caunes concerné que
j'allais dire les petits et les moyens
clients ceux pour qui il a fallu trouver
des réponses clé en main rapide et
efficace la plupart des très grande
structuration de réinvestissement de
l'argent non déclaré en france se fait
au travers de l'assurance-vie
luxembourgeoise un certain nombre de nos
palaces parisiens ont été rachetés de
cette façon par aussi des intérêts
français et la france croit toujours ce
sont des intérêts étrangers mais
derrière ce sont des grands noms
français qui en apparence fédère autour
d'eux des investisseurs institutionnels
notamment luxembourgeois on sait tous
que les sociétés d'assurances
investissent dans l'immobilier pour
investir leurs primes c'est donc
cosmétiques mans tout à fait cohérent et
donc c'est ce genre de technique qui est
utilisée aujourd'hui qui sont des
techniques qui est en fait sont
cosmétiques mans acceptable on au départ
une motivation économique réelle
mais sont utilisés pour faire de l'off
shore pur à 100% avant on a quitté le
monde de la valise de billets pour pour
finalement utiliser ces techniques
l'autre grande technique aussi pour le
réinvestissement des capitaux non
déclarés
c'est bien sûr les prêts lombard les
pré-ados et c'est une des grandes
pratiques des banques françaises pour
rapatrier l'argent de leurs clients non
déclarés de genève
je souhaite j'ai de l'argent non déclaré
en suisse je souhaite faire une
acquisition immobilière en france que je
revendrai ce qui me permettra d'ailleurs
de blanchir complètement le produit de
la fraude mais en tout cas je peux
vouloir aussi faire un investissement en
apparence je sollicite un prêt auprès
d'un établissement français ou un
établissement étranger ayant une licence
bancaire en france est habilité à
octroyer des prêts officiellement la
banque sont garantis par une hypothèque
sur mon bien immobilier fait une vague
étude de solvabilité personnel prend
deux vagues d'hypothèque sur des biens
des biens complémentaires mais en
réalité la vraie garantie pour cette
banque c'est une garantie or livre qui
est donnée par la filiale suisse à sa
maison mère parisienne
il y a une double comptabilité il ya une
comptabilité parallèle il y a des
contrats parallèle qui ne que vous ne
trouverez jamais auprès des banques
françaises mais la banque française sait
très bien que s'il ya un défaut sur le
remboursement du prêt immobilier
et bien c'est par exemple je ne les
prends pas parce que je les vis mais on
sont les sites purement à titre
d'exemple et bien la filiale immobilière
du groupe bnp paribas qui s'appelle
l'ucb à genève avec grâce aux équipes de
bnp paribas genève donne une garantie
discrète à sa maison mère parisienne qui
fait que s'il ya un problème
eh bien ça l'ucb ou bnp paribas genève
n'aura même pas à rembourser la maison
mère la maison-mère passera sa commun un
prêt douteux mais les actifs seront
saisis et en plus de ça ils seront
saisis dans un endroit où la banque paye
le très peu d'impôts par rapport par
rapport à la france donc c'est même
presque une bonne nouvelle si vous
voulez quand un client monte une
opération comme celle là et qu'il ne
rembourse pas parce qu'on se sert dans
son portefeuille non déclarés
puis ça permet aussi à l'établissement
français de ne pas nécessairement
déclaré cette cette saisie de garantie
et d'accumuler une trésorerie très
gentiment en dehors de france
donc voilà donc aujourd'hui les
techniques ont changé elles se sont
sophistiquées
on a simplement déplacer le curseur on a
monté le curseur un peu plus haut
finalement on ne fait peur qu'aux gens
qui sont peu sophistiquée mal conseillé
les commissions de dégrisement les
cellules de dégrisement que nous avons
mis en place qui n'ont de dégrisement
que le nom d'ailleurs n'ont finalement
attiré que les petits les gens qui
d'ailleurs n'était souvent pas les
acteurs c'était plutôt des gens qui
avaient hérité de choses on utilise ne
savait pas trop comment se dépêtrer
finalement et qui en particulier été
aussi mal mal ou pas du tout conseillé
non seulement l'argent le vrai argent de
la fraude est parti plus loin mais il
sait opacifier mais on trouve toujours
d'excellentes technique pour le faire
rentrer on n'a plus besoin des porteurs
de valises ou des banquiers sympathique
qui amène 9999 euros pour ne pas être à
dix mille au passage de au passage des
douanes
ça continue pour rendre service mais les
choses se sont beaucoup sophistiqués
donc voilà donc le problème existe
toujours il est allé plus loin et il
cette île c'est opacifier c'est tout les
techniques que vous décrivez donc
implique les banques bien sûr mais les
les marchés financiers également
d'autres opérateurs d'autres acteurs
financiers puisque c'est notre
commission porte sur cet aspect là les
banques bien skié acteurs financiers
est-ce que ça les impliquent également
les les banques sont les premiers
acteurs du système que je décris c'est à
dire que les banques ont développé en
leur sein des équipes dites d'ingénierie
patrimoniale qui suivent très très
précisément ces questions là et qui sont
les premiers à recommander recommandé
ces pratiques
à tel point que lorsque vous allez à
paris ou à londres en particulier à
paris c'est toujours très amusant aux
différentes conférences dit de fiscalité
d'ingénierie patrimoniale ou de family
office organisés par des sociétés
françaises monégasque anglo saxon la
première chose qu'on vous dit dans les
cinq premières minutes après avoir pris
un café c'est rassurez vous on a
qualifié la salle n'y a aucun
représentant de l'administration entre
nous on peut se parler et ses
conférences se tiennent
tours de 2 300 m le noble lieu dans
lequel nous nous trouvons et beaucoup dé
gens qui sont et dans le public et dans
les intervenants de ces conférences sont
les ingénieurs patrimoniaux des banques
françaises des banques étrangères en
france donc les banques sont les
principaux acteurs ce sont elles qui
vont chercher la la la la valeur ajoutée
aussi là aussi également au sens unique
du terme auprès des grands cabinets
d'avocats ou des cabinets d'avocats plus
plus plus obscurs 1 à paris et ce sont
les banques qui fédère tous les
professionnels nécessaires
mais aujourd'hui les banques les banques
ont compris qu'il y avait d'autres
façons d'aider la fraude
vous avez des classes d'actifs au delà
des marchés financiers qui sont très
favorables parce que déjà naturellement
peu taxés et en plus de ça tout à fait
tangibles et tout à fait mobile c'est
notamment le cas du monde de l'art c'est
notamment effectivement le cas de
l'immobilier mais c'est pour ça que les
la plupart des grandes banques sur la
place de paris n'ont pas ouvert des
départements art pour la beauté de parce
qu'ils se sont réveillés avec un
supplément d'âme esthétique un beau
matin c'est simplement que s'il ya bien
un marché qui permet avec d'autres comme
le marché des matières précieuses le
marché du diamant de pouvoir de pouvoir
mener une fraude à plus grande échelle
et de façon beaucoup moins surveillés et
régulés que sur les marchés financiers
c'est bien le sait bien le monde de
l'art et en plus grâce à monsieur
fabrice frère ça n'entre même pas dans
la base de calcul de liesse fc
formidable mais c'est pour ça que le
port franc de genève celui qui s'ouvre
qui est en construction à luxembourg et
qui vient de s'ouvrir
à singapour ont de beaux jours devant
devant peu et là aussi les banques avec
d'autres mais en particulier les banques
sont sont très présentes dans quelques
jours jeudi s'ouvre une des plus grandes
foires d'art d'europe qui est la foire
d'art de bâle dont le sponsor principal
je vous le rappelle l ubs mais ce
président avec votre permission donc
deux questions de passer la parole à mes
collègues
est ce que vous diriez qu'il existe un
système européen de gestion des avoirs
dissimulés qui impliquerait donc
certains états et par quels circuits
financiers passerait-il aussi si vous
répondez par la positive et ensuite vous
avez évoqué la faute d'un système
beaucoup plus que celui d'un homme à
propos de la sphère que vous avez
évoquées vous avez évoqué donc des
personnels et personnalités politiques
de tous bords qui détiendrait qu'ils
détenaient des comptes dissimulés
comment avez vous eu connaissance de
cette situation
alors je vais commencer par votre
deuxième question j'ai eu connaissance
de cette situation pour en avoir été le
été le témoin le témoin direct
différent de mes employeurs m'ont
demandé d'apporter un conseil ou
d'intervenir dans le cadre de dossiers
ou très clairement avait été identifié
derrière un certain nombre de structures
des personnalités politiques très
directement ou des personnalité proches
d'un certain nombre de partis politiques
et agissant comme l'or comme leur
soutien financier dont mon témoignage ne
repose pas sur j'allais dire à leur ont
dit de la place de jeux de genève où
d'autres où beaucoup de gens parlent
sans nécessairement avoir vu beaucoup de
choses et surf un peu sur l'actualité
pour se rendre intéressant dans les
dîners en ville mais cela repose sur la
connaissance de dossiers de dossiers
très précis sur lesquels j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'entretenir avec les
enquêteurs
donc voilà la réponse à votre votre
deuxième deuxième question
j'ajouterai néanmoins que les soutiens
politiques sont parfois tout à fait
subtilement déguisée au travers d'un
certain nombre de j'allais dire
d'institutions périphériques qui peuvent
être prendre la forme de deux de deux
cercles de cercle de réflexion de
cercles d'affaires mondain je dirais et
qui sont en fait très opportunément
utilisés pour servir de servir
d'intermédiaire aussi donc ya pas que l'
approche directe et une approche une
approche indirecte pour répondre à votre
première première question je crois que
finalement lorsque vous regardez les
quelques affaires qui ont pu émerger
notamment en france depuis depuis
l'après deuxième guerre mondiale
il est évident que parmi les plus grands
utilisateurs de ces places ont été nos
grandes entreprises qui ont utilisé ces
structures
évidemment pour gérer leur trésorerie
mais aussi parfois pour régler des
commissions licites ou illicites sur un
certain nombre de contrats nos services
secrets également ont été très
utilisateurs de ces structures pour la
bonne cause quand il s'agissait de faire
des règlements de prix de taz pour leur
libération
et donc il ya une maîtrise parfaite
parfaite de d'un certain nombre
d'instances étatique des techniques de
dissimulation
et il est très facile quand on a
expérimenté ces techniques pour la bonne
cause de la raison d'état de les
utiliser pour des raisons qui sont
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins public est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus privé et ces
circuits sont utilisés par la plupart
des par la plupart des états des états
européens certainement je n'irai pas
jusqu'à rentrer dans la théorie du
complot avec des systèmes parallèles on
avait beaucoup parlé à l'époque de la
fameuse chambre de compensation
clearstream qui certainement comme
d'autres a pu être utilisées mais
aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin de ça vous
avez vous avez chez les banques
ce qu'on appelle on a on a dit beaucoup
de bêtises sur les dénominations de
compte on a parlé de comptes omnibus on
allonge et j'ai tout vu dans la presse
française
mais il ya néanmoins chez les banquiers
ce qu'on appelle des comptes de passage
les comptes de passage sont pas du tout
ce qu'on a décrit au départ une zone
utilisation tout à fait licite qui est
que lorsque vous achetez alors c'est
moins vrai aujourd'hui où les
transactions se font de plus en plus en
date de valeur même jour mais vous avez
un serveur de transactions sur des
produits complexes notamment sur
certains marchés qui demande entre
l'ordre et le règlement livraison entre
1 2 3 et 5 jours et bien sûr les banques
font des poules d'ordre pour leurs
différents clients et avant qu'il y ait
un règlement livraison elles ne peuvent
pas affecter les transactions par
portion alors différents clients elles
sont donc obligées de deux bouquets
temporairement ses transactions sur des
comptes de passage dont le titulaire est
la banque elle-même c'est-à-dire que le
banquier devient son propre banquier et
puis au bout de trois jours ou cinq
jours on se doit d'affecter les
différentes transactions aux comptes
concernés et au départ c'est une
utilisation tout à fait licite de cette
technique bancaire
aujourd'hui la quasi-totalité de ses
comptes de passage sont utilisés pour
permettre la dissimulation du trajet
réel de
lors de la fermeture et de la
réouverture de la ré ouverture de compte
donc quand on propose un client
notamment de transformer ses avoirs
détenus à titre personnel au travers
d'une société ou d'un trust dans une
assurance-vie luxembourgeoise comme je
voulais dit quand des établissements
comme réel ubs ou d'autres fermes des
comptes en suisse pour les envoyer à
singapour
on n'a pas envie que l'émetteur sache
qui est le récepteur et vice et versa et
donc on utilise très largement ses
comptes
on les utilise dans un certain nombre de
juridictions pour brouiller encore plus
pour brouiller encore plus les pistes et
donc aujourd'hui on a ces techniques qui
sont très largement très largement
utilisés mais j'allais presque vous dire
que l âge et pas du tout un point de vue
de témoins c'est un point de vue externe
je suis encore sidéré de voir qu'on a
vraiment pas besoin d'aller en suisse
pour faire tout ça
j'ai souvenir de lire un certain nombre
de déclarations à propos d'une affaire
dont je n'ai plus jamais entendu parler
qui était lui ai même où on a vu des
millions d'euros sortir en liquide d'âge
ans de banques françaises à paris ce qui
ne pour vous ne pourriez plus faire
aujourd'hui même en suisse est-ce qu'on
a eu la moindre suite sur le fait que
des sommes d'une telle ampleur ont été
livrés en liquide quelle que soit
l'utilisation qui était présenté à
l'époque je n'en ai pas souvenir et donc
j'ai presque envie de vous dire quand je
vois les pratiques des banques
françaises ici parce que moi j'ai vécu
je suis désolé je vais être un peu long
j'ai vécu une expérience assez
incroyable je travaillais pour une une
famille britannique qui s'appelle la
famille un broc qui est une grande
famille britannique manqué de la reine
depuis depuis de nombreuses générations
et ces gens là du fait d'une dissensions
familiales ont vendu leurs banques à une
banque qui s'appelle la société générale
et j'ai vécu le changement de culture
entre en brosse et la société générale
où on a demandé aux équipes de wolf
planning d'aller dans toutes les régions
rencontrer ce qu'ils appelaient les cgip
conseiller en gestion gestionnaire de
patrimoine indépendants que c'était un
peu les conseillers fiscaux qui
conseillait les agences et les
directions régionales et la société
générale elle le fait encore d'ailleurs
organiser des joutes
c'est à dire qu'elle prend un cas
d'école et dans la salle il y a un
représentant de la suisse
un représentant de londres un
représentant de la belgique
représentant de singapour et chacun
vient d'expliquer très très très
tranquillement la façon dont il aurait
aidé ses clients à sortir ces actifs de
france ou à protéger ses actifs et et
après c'est un peu aux directeurs
régionaux qui viennent de lille bordeaux
rennes peu importe finalement devoir qui
a été un petit peu le plus convaincant
les coordonnées de ces messieurs sont
données et ensuite on explique que s'ils
ont des clients qui ont ces besoins
surtout surtout n'écrivez rien surtout
surtout ne simplement organiser un
rendez-vous opportunément de l'autre
côté de la frontière quelle qu'elle soit
et et voilà et donc j'ai vécu notamment
un grave incident entre monsieur bouton
et l'un de ses plus gros clients à la
fois entreprises et clients privés qui
est la plus grande famille de
distribution en france qui organisait
des choses à partir de lg en bronze et
qui quand elle s'est aperçue
contrairement à ce qui lui avait été
promis par monsieur bouton que monsieur
bouton et ses équipes était était
totalement au courant de ce qui a été
fait au niveau trust talent par sept
familles ont décidé de ne plus être
client de la société générale et la
société générale a perdu son plus gros
clients privés et entreprises
à cette occasion donc si vous voulez
voilà c'est un c'est un système qui est
complètement qui est complètement
généralisée et encore une fois je pense
que les mesures qui sont considérés
aujourd'hui qui ferait en sorte qu'on
fasse des comparaisons de comptabilité
entre pour voir si éventuellement il ya
des actifs non d'ici qui sont dissimulés
par les filiales étrangères des banques
françaises me semble d'une dune d'une
efficacité null null vis-à-vis de ces
pratiques qui sont indétectables par de
simples moyens de comparaison comptable
d'essayer de réconcilier des masse sous
gestion parce que les techniques y en a
plein d'autres
hormis celle que je vous ai décrit très
brièvement aujourd'hui ne serait pas ne
serait pas révélée par c'est donc donc
en fait on ne fait que botter en touche
pour l'instant
merci beaucoup je vais passer la parole
jean yves le conte à titre personnel je
joue bien entendu expliqué c'est très
intéressant sur le fait que les états
eux mêmes sont particulièrement
connaisseur de toutes les techniques
d'optimisation et là c'est plus de
l'optimisation c'est de l'opacité
fiscale par les services de
renseignement ou avait parlé des
différents bords de l'échiquier
politique
est ce que les partis politiques
j'entends les partis politiques par les
personnes elles mêmes par les personnes
physiques sont aussi des évadés fiscaux
absolument je vais au ciné d'une petite
une petite anecdote lorsque j'ai pris
mes responsabilités à la direction de
l'ump en suisse nous étions juste avant
l'élection présidentielle de 2007 et
notre activité parce que aussi c'est bon
à rappeler la communauté française de
suisse est faite de tout un tas de gens
qui n'ont rien à voir avec le monde de
la gestion de fortune qui sont
cuisiniers serveurs cadres salariés et
c'est même la vaste majorité de cette
communauté et donc nous souhaitions
accueillir des grandes personnalités ump
pour venir parler des sujets importants
de la présidentielle à venir
en 2007 nous en avons accueilli un
certain nombre et dont monsieur woerth
et devedjian
c'est la première fois que je les
rencontrais
plein de bonne volonté nous leur avons
proposé d'avoir des voitures qui les
attendent à la gare de genève on nous a
dit non non ces messieurs viennent en
avion on dirait que cela ne tienne on
ira faire en sorte que des voitures les
attentes pour les emmener au sur le lieu
de la première réunion publique et ces
messieurs sont en fait arrivé dans
l'avion privé d'un des mains d une des
grandes fortunes délocaliser en suisse
qui soutient ce parti et d'autres
d'ailleurs qui a d'ailleurs soutenu
l'opposant en 2012 et la première chose
qui nous a été dit avant même de nous
dire bonjour c'est officiellement nous
sommes arrivés en trains et vous fermez
vos gueules
voilà je vous donne je vous donne un
exemple de gens qui deux mois plus tard
ont prétendu ne pas me connaître ne pas
connaître mes équipes et qui pourtant
ont passé toute une soirée et bien plus
d'une soirée avec nous je le sais
purement un titre d'anecdote je viens à
l'art est une réponse à votre à votre
question quand j'ai repris les rênes de
l'ump j'ai eu droit à un accès à toute
la correspondance et à toutes les
archives de l'ump en suisse au travers
des différents responsables politiques
précédents j ai vu des choses absolument
aberrante aberrante scandaleuse et je
m'en suis ouvert à l'époque à la
personne qui qui représentait le parti
socialiste en suisse et nous en sommes
tous les deux venus à la conclusion de
la nos différences de sensibilité qui
l'avait vu des choses tout à fait
similaire de son de son côté gt gt sur
place quand j'ai rencontré ces hommes
politiques dans le cadre aussi bien les
activités politiques que mes activités
professionnelles
j'ai entendu leur discours et il est
évident que bon nombre de personnalités
politiques qui au départ ont fait des
choses à titre d'un enrichissement
personnel ont ensuite mis à disposition
les techniques qu'ils avaient créée pour
eux mêmes à la disposition ou d'un
certain nombre de l'ocs de leurs
collègues ou à la disposition de leur
parti donc aujourd'hui quand je parle de
la classe politique française je parle à
la fois d'hommes et de femmes politiques
pour leur enrichissement personnel et
aussi en soutien des partis qu'ils
représentent
s'ils furent reprises et moi la parole à
mon collègue jean yves le conte
merci bien je suis désolé mais je vais
donc j'ai dû partir dans cinq minutes
parce que j'ai je viens de vous écouter
je partage votre appréciation de la
communauté française en suisse vous avez
dit des choses très très graves sur la
classe politique française en général
vous avez dit tout à l'heure une réponse
partielle à ma question que je voudrais
les apprécie pas précisé quand même la
réponse que vous en étiez ouvert aux
enquêteurs parce que ce que vous dites
vous pouvez vous vous dites je sais des
choses est ce que tout ce que vous savez
a été transmis à la justice
quand vous parlez d'un représentant du
parti socialiste en suisse est ce qu'on
peut connaître le nom pour savoir si
parce que je veux dire c'est logique
quand on met en cause toute une classe
politique de dire les choses jusqu'au
bout et pas de simplement participer à
la création d'une ambiance parce qu'il
faut aussi pouvoir donner les outils
pour donner à la justice les moyens de
fonctionner et de juger les délits
et puis au delà puisque vous nous
décrivez sur le système est ce que vous
pouvez donner rapidement aux
responsables politiques qui sont là
malgré l'appréciation faite globalement
sur sur le monde politique est ce que la
priorité c'est l'harmonisation fiscale
ou une autre régulation des opérateurs
financiers
alors pour répondre à votre première
question j'ai abordé pour l'instant avec
les enquêteurs que ce soit les
différents services de la brigade
financière ainsi que les douanes
judiciaires ainsi que le jugement de
rhinebeck et certains de ses collègues
l'examen très détaillé et documentée de
pratique je n'ai pour l'instant pour des
questions j'espère vous l'apprécierez
notamment de sécurité personnelle est
encore dans l'environnement suisse pas
fourni un certain nombre de noms
néanmoins j'ai rédigé un document avec
en annexe
toutes les pièces permettant de prouver
très de façon vous avez raison de le
rappeler c'est important de façon très
tangible ce que j'avance
toutes ces documents ces notes ont été
consignés au parti du auprès d'une
partie tiers ils seront destinés le jour
où je serai dans le bon environnement
pour le faire à être communiqué avec
tout les éléments de preuve nécessaires
pour qu'on ne soit pas dans la simple
rumeur
mais qu'on soit vraiment dans des choses
tout à fait tout à fait tangibles
voilà pour la votre première votre
première question
pour votre deuxième question est là
vraiment c'est un avis purement
personnel
mais la vie quand même de quelqu'un qui
au quotidien par heureusement aussi à
beaucoup de clients qui n'ont pas du
tout deux problématiques de d'argent non
déclaré
heureusement il y en a encore mais aussi
à ceux qui en ont je crois que si nous
avions et je n'aborde pas du tout une
partie politique plutôt plutôt qu'une
autre si nous avions un vrai courage
politique en france nous aurions dû
comprendre depuis longtemps que le passé
est le passé nous ne pourrons jamais y
revenir dessus
et qu'à force d'être dans le
politiquement correct et de s'asseoir
sur nos grands pères et de nos grandes
pratique nos grands principes
républicains
on en arrive à ne faire que des demi
mesures qui ne font qu'aggraver les
problèmes à mon avis ce qu'il fallait
faire c'est avoir le courage politique
de dire l'argent non déclaré est déjà
sortie de france
si nous continuons à l'est dans le sens
où nous allons c'est exactement ce que
je disais tout à l'heure non seulement
il ira plus loin mais il ne fera que
s'opacifier et nous ne rapatrieront
finalement vraiment qu'à la marge
cet argent soit s'il fallait faire ces
s'inspirer du modèle non pas que ce pays
m'inspire plus qu'un autre mais il ya
quand même quelques modèles intéressants
s'inspirait du scudo italien faire en
sorte de mettre en place un rapatriement
sur une base anonyme parce qu'aucun
client quel que soit l'absence de
pénalités ne rapatrierait de fonds si le
processus est un processus nominatif
parce que dans la grande tradition
française
tout le monde sait très bien que
quelques années plus tard d'autres
problèmes arriveront donc pouvoir le
faire sur une base anonyme avec
effectivement une pénalisation c'est
juste mais une pénalisation qui ne soit
pas confiscatoire
mais par contre pour réconcilier cet
avantage finalement qui pourrait être
perçu comme un avantage indû à des gens
qui ont été les fraudeurs la vraie
réponse et 2 contres
un drain le réinvestissement de cet
argent et je crois qu'il aurait fallu
dire c'est que voilà on le dit les
donnant-donnant vous rapatrier sur une
base anonyme avec des pénalités qu'on
peut considérer comme acceptables et pas
mais l'argent rapatrier devra forcément
s'investir pourquoi pas dans un grand
emprunt d'état et ni spécialement à
cette occasion qui lui même pourrait
servir au financement de la vie publique
française à la création d'entreprise à
tous nos besoins à tous nos besoins
publics et je peux vous assurer pour en
avoir parlé très précisément et
fréquemment avec un certain nombre de
gens que cette mesure pourrait concerner
qu'elle serait extrêmement efficace
extrêmement efficace seulement nous
n'avons pas proposé nous offrons des
cellules de dégrisement qui n'en sont
pas nous nous avons toujours peur
par peur du qu'en dira-t-on et du
politiquement correct de proposer une
amnistie qui est toujours perçu de façon
très sulfureuse en france aucune des
mesures qui sont proposées par le
gouvernement actuel n'aurait empêché la
sphère qui a usé
parce que quand vous avez en face de
vous quelqu'un qui est dans le mensonge
et dans l'obscur ça n'est pas des jeux
ne sont pas des déclarations d'honneur
où des vérifications sur des choses qui
par définition ne sont pas connus
puisqu'elles viennent du mensonge que
vous allez changer les choses
mon opinion personnelle et qu' il serait
peut-être temps que l occasion de cette
affaire et de tout ce que nous vivons en
france nous puissions nous poser la
question de savoir pourquoi depuis 60
ans chaque fois qu'un entrepreneur
réussi où chaque fois qu'une
pourquoi le premier réflexe c'est un
réflexe de est un réflexe de départ où
est un réflexe de est un réflexe de
fraude
il faudrait peut-être se demander
pourquoi aujourd'hui je n'exclus
absolument pas les pratiques des
politiques dont nous avons parlé
pourquoi dans la façon dont nous
rémunérons peut-être très mal et très
bas nos personnels politiques dans la
façon dont nous contraignons
le financement des partis politiques
pourquoi finalement nous ne faisons que
le créer un système qui est encore une
fois mes propos ne sont pas des propos
d'absolution qui ne font qu'encourager
les pratiques que nous remarquons donc
le problème c'est un problème de fond
c'est un problème mais là on pourra y
passer des jours et et nos gouvernements
ils passent des années ça n'est pas une
harmonisation 6,7 en plus une
harmonisation vers le haut comme ça
semble être le cas dans l'environnement
européen qui changera quoi que ce soit
je crois qu'il ya une réflexion vraiment
en amont sur l'intégralité du système
fiscal français mais en tout cas déjà
résoudre le passé et de se dire que si
on ne fait rien l'argent ne rentrera pas
alors autant être pragmatique et le
faire revenir
je peux vous assurer que les sommes
collectées nous permettrait déjà d'avoir
une influence très positive sur
l'ensemble de nos besoins de financement
dans toutes les catégories politiques
abordé par nos par nos ministes donc cet
exercice me semble pas être un exercice
inutile il faut penser à l'avenir mais
si on pouvait déjà réglé le passé non
pas au travers des accords tic rubik qui
sont proposés par les suisses parce que
c'est un leurre mais au travers d'une
décision française dans le sens que j'ai
décrit ça me semble être une idée une
idée à considérer merci beaucoup nous
reste 14 minutes alors les dernières
questions sont comme je les ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est le dieu du rapporteur
j'en ai tout de même une petite je vous
ai entendu dire tout à l'heure que en
fait vous aviez préparé pour l'époque où
vous seriez dans un environnement plus
favorable
un certain nombre de renseignements et
d'informations et quelle est la nature
de l'environnement défavorable que vous
subissiez l'heure actuelle nous avons
été favorable il est très clair
contrairement à monsieur phal kiani qui
est intervenu hier de façon très
hypocrite sur sur france 2
je ne venais pas de liste à proposer je
n'ai pas encore moins à vendre je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas un jugement moral sur
l'ensemble des personnes dont nous avons
dont nous allons parler des pratiques
aujourd'hui ma motivation depuis le
début de mes interventions a été
uniquement de dénoncer des gens qui sont
qui n'ont même pas l'honnêteté morale de
ne serait-ce que se taire face aux
pratiques qui s'appliquent à eux mêmes
j'en veux simplement aux donneurs de
leçons et aux moralisateurs dans
l'environnement français qui sont les
premiers acteurs du système qu'il
dénonce dès qu'ils franchissent la
frontière et feront preuve d'une
schizophrénie totale et c'est donc ces
pratiques là et uniquement ces pratiques
là dans un acte citoyen désintéressés
que je dénoncerai preuves à l'appui
la raison pour laquelle je ne le fait
pas aujourd'hui sont liés à des raisons
tout à fait personnelles et familiales
ma situation actuelle est une situation
très clair c'est une situation de menace
de menaces sur mon intégrité physique
sur celle de ma famille d'un exercice
systématique de décridibilisation de ma
personne à titre personnel et
professionnel auprès de l'ensemble de
mes interlocuteurs mais c'est une ce
sont surtout des menaces exprimées de
façon très différente sur mon intégrité
physique et celle de ma famille est donc
le jour où je pourrai efficacement me
sentir ne plus me sentir en tout cas
beaucoup moins de sentir lève possibles
victimes de ces menaces c'est le jour où
je sortirai ces éléments j'ai déjà une
idée très précise des canaux par
lesquels ça se fera épistolaire et non
épistolaire mais cela se fera des
dernières questions de notre à porter
oui après ses déclarations très très
profond d extrêmement grave on va
redescendre au niveau des chiffres sans
être très longue puisque au bond la rive
haut de gamme et c'est très important
combien de comptes dissimulés
correspondant à combien de personnes
avez vous pu identifier ans pour quel
montant
deuxième chiffre que je serais intéressé
de connaître combien concernés
des hommes ou femmes exerçant des
responsabilités politiques
y at il des ministres exeo exercée sous
l'ancienne législature et sous
l'actuelle et dernière question par
rapport à la suisse est-ce que vous
pensez que l'état suisse peut conforter
ses positions dans les négociations
internationales difficile sur le sujet à
partir de la connaissance qu'elle a de
certaines situations fiscales de
responsables politiques étrangers et
dernière question plus personnelle par
rapport à ce que vous venez de dire sur
le climat est-ce que vous bénéficiez de
mesures de protection
j'essaie de prendre vos questions l'une
après l'autre en terme de témoignages de
situations d'actifs non déclaré que j'ai
pu voir depuis 20 ans je suis incapable
de vous donner une statistique très
précise mais on parle certainement de de
plusieurs de plusieurs centaines de
plusieurs centaines de comptes dont les
tailles à l'aide
d'une centaine de milliers d'euros
jusqu'à des montants pour un certain
nombre de deux grands acteurs à des
montants qui parfois pas nécessairement
sur un compte mais si on parle de la
relation bold les relations bancaires
non déclarés d'ensemble pour vous pouvez
être a largement dépassé le milliard
d'euros pour pour certaines pour
certaines familles le nombre de
situations politiques directes dont je
peux témoigner représente à peu près une
quinzaine d'individus à l'intérieur
desquels se trouvent des responsables
politiques ministres et de la précédente
et de l'actuelle majorité
et pardon votre dernière question qui
nous concerne et à titre personnel je ne
bénéficie aujourd'hui d'aucune mesure de
protection
je n'en ai pas demandé j'arrive du tgv
de de lausanne et genre partirait demain
demain en fin de journée
c'est peut-être une c'est peut-être une
erreur c'est en tout cas ma situation
actuelle est votre dernière votre
dernière question que j'oublie à
l'instant excusez moi concernant la
suisse est ce que la suisse peut
profiter entre guillemets de cette
connaissance là et la suisse si vous
voulez il faut pas oublier en attendant
nous français à voir les choses en
fonction de notre propre paradigme pour
les suisses vous prenez la ferc à usak
un établissement comme brel et compagnie
dans l'environnement suisse reyl &
company n'a rien fait de mal
reyl & company a violé toutes les lois
françaises en matière de blanchiment de
fraude fiscale en matière de transport
de cash sur le territoire français en
matière de de démarchage illicite sur le
territoire français mais dans
l'environnement suit ces établissements
n'ont rien fait donc là seul problème le
seul problème des suisses et de ne pas
trop mettre en cause des opérateurs qui
sont parmi leurs plus gros contribuables
et les plus gros employeurs de leurs
économies tout en respectant aussi les
intérêts des autres groupes industriels
qui eux dans des intérêts complètement
différent de celui des banques
la suisse est un animal avec 2
de moitié de cerveau l'industrie
financière pour qui l' harmonisation
européenne notamment n'est pas une bonne
chose pour qui la transparence n'est pas
une bonne chose
et au contraire le monde industriel les
nestlé novartis et autres qui veulent
ces intégrations pour pouvoir vendre
sans limitation et discrimination leur
produit donc c'est un pays qui est très
schizophrène et où ses intérêts
économiques s'entrechoquent en
permanence donc pour la suisse si vous
voulez leur seul souci aujourd'hui n'est
pas de se dire le secret bancaire était
une mauvaise une mauvaise chose à titre
à titre moral oui certains partis
politiques le 10 mai mais très peu c'est
de dire comment est ce qu'on sorte de
cette situation et d'un monde qui
finalement a permis à nos banques de ce
contre de se construire depuis depuis
plusieurs générations
je crois néanmoins je reviens sur ce que
je disais tout à l'heure la
problématique française pour les suisses
n'a rien à voir avec la problématique
américaine parce que demain très
sincèrement s'il ubs lombard odier
pictet et d'autres perdre leur licence
bancaire en france
ça va pas changer grand chose à
l'échelle des masses de ces maisons
d'autant plus que ils n'ont pas
véritablement beaucoup percer le marché
institutionnel français
donc même s'ils perdent quelques clients
quelques clients résidents ça n'est pas
très grave
et puis je pense qu'ils ont un sentiment
d'impunité qu'ils n'ont pas quand ils
ont les états unis en face d'eux est mon
analyse né de mon expérience et que si
les suisses se sentent un sentiment
peut-être pas d'impunité mais en tout
cas de d'assez grand confort c'est
qu'ils savent très bien qu'ils sont dans
leur livre est d'abord un grand merci
aux secours damage habits à pouvoir
intervention ça me rappelle une émission
de télévision il ya quelques années sur
france 2 qui s'appelait l'heure de
vérité j'ai l'impression l'heure avec
une heure de vérité utile une demande
que jouerait vous formulez ou non de la
commission si le président et les
collègues en sont d'accord
est-ce que vous soyez disposés à nous
rencontrer dans un autre cas un autre
mouvement pour expliquer les techniques
un jeu pas bien les techniques dont vous
avez apporté quelques exemples
extrêmement intéressant parce que nous
sommes preneurs de l'ingénierie à
l'oeuvre et j'imagine que vous
connaissez d'autres systèmes entre
guillemets et nous serions si on était
d'accord demandeurs d'un entretien
ultérieur dans un autre cadre au moins
un oiseau officiels n'ont pas leur
destin mais en tête à tête avec l'équipe
pour vous expliquer les techniques
proprement dit
alors je suis à votre disposition merci
beaucoup vont déterminer exactement dans
l'horaire prévu je compte tenu de
l'actualité de votre audition
je pense que toute la commission sera
d'accord avec moi pour souhaiter que
votre environnement deviennent beaucoup
plus paisible et libère des informations
qui nous aurait beaucoup intéressé je
remercie
voilà donc pour cette audition qui avait
lieu mercredi dernier devant la
commission d'enquêté sur le rôle des
banques dans l'évasion fiscale la
commission denquête qui poursuivent bien
entendu cette semaine et dans les jours
qui viennent
eh bien ces auditions des auditions que
vous pouvez retrouver sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr ou également sur
le site internet du sénat
je vous souhaite à tous une très bonne
journée sur notre antenne